OK, here's a joke that US servicemen in Iraq just love. This brings down the house, according to Tom Irwin, a comedian who just spent over a month entertaining troops in the Sunni Triangle, in Fallujah, in Mosul, near the border with Iran, all over the place. He came into the studio and told me the joke.
好的，这是一个驻伊拉克的美国军人非常喜欢的笑话。据托马斯·欧文（Tom Irwin）说，这个笑话能让全场沸腾。欧文是一位喜剧演员，他刚刚在逊尼三角地带、费卢杰、摩苏尔、伊朗边境附近以及其他许多地方为部队进行了超过一个月的表演。他来到演播室，给我讲了这个笑话。
Black Hawk helicopters, I love them. I love the pilots. We've gotten to know many of the Black Hawk helicopter pilots. And I love Black Hawk helicopters. I do know a group of people who hate them. And those would be Iraqi sheep farmers.
“黑鹰”直升机，我爱死它们了。我爱那些飞行员。我们已经认识了许多“黑鹰”直升机的飞行员。我确实喜爱“黑鹰”直升机。不过，我也认识一群讨厌它们的人，那就是伊拉克的牧羊人。
And that joke would kill.
那个笑话绝对会火。
Yeah, no, it's yeah, it's very strong. Because that's how everybody gets around. Because you fly very low. So you can see the people. You can see them. So it has to do with-- and you watch all the animals scatter. So it's kind of, OK, Babu, OK, last one in the pen, OK, and then, tt-tt-tt-tt-tt-tt-tt-tt-tt. Ah! American! It's just this, I don't know, I'm sorry. I can't keep describing.
是啊，不，它确实非常给力。因为那是每个人出行的方式，因为飞行高度极低，所以你能看见人，你能清楚地看见他们。所以这跟……你看着所有动物四散奔逃有关。所以场景就像是：好了，巴巴，最后一个赶进圈里，好了，然后，哒哒哒哒哒哒！啊！美国人！这真是……我不知道，我很抱歉，我没法继续描述下去了。
It's so hard to leave that out there. Because it's just like, I am just so conditioned to have it have a different reaction. I'm sorry. I'm sitting in this studio, just like, oh my God. This is the greatest bad reaction I've ever heard.
要把这些内容删掉太难了。因为我已经被训练出了一种完全不同的反应。我很抱歉。我坐在演播室里，简直……天哪，这是我听过最棒的“差评”反馈。
Listeners here in the United States may think we have some idea of what is going on among the American forces in Iraq. But really, we don't know their day-to-day lives. We don't know their habits. We don't know what annoys them most. We do not even understand their jokes. As Tom Irwin says--
美国的听众可能以为我们对伊拉克美军的现状有所了解，但实际上，我们并不了解他们的日常生活。我们不知道他们的习惯。我们不知道什么最让他们心烦。我们甚至听不懂他们的笑话。正如托马斯·欧文所说——
You have to be in Iraq, sort of.
你得身在伊拉克才行，某种程度上是这样。
And so today on our radio program, an attempt to bridge the gap between the 140,000 Americans stationed in Iraq and the 290 million of us back home. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
所以今天在我们的广播节目中，我们试图架起一座桥梁，连接驻伊拉克的14万美军与国内的2.9亿同胞。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Today on our show, trying to find cigarettes in Fallujah. What US training tells you you should do if you hit a roadside bomb, versus what you should actually do, if you want to live. And what insurgents play over loudspeakers that freaks out Americans, and what Americans play to freak out Iraqis. We have two stories on our show today. Act One, we spend some time with some National Guardsmen a few miles from Baghdad. Act Two, our own Jack Hitt talks about what the Battle of Fallujah was really like with a marine lieutenant who commanded a platoon in Charlie Company, a lieutenant who also happens to be his nephew. Stay with us.
今天在节目中，我们将讨论在费卢杰寻找香烟的经历。美军训练手册告诉你在遇到路边炸弹时应该怎么做，而如果你想活命，实际上你应该怎么做。此外，还有叛乱分子通过扩音器播放什么内容会让美国人感到恐惧，以及美国人播放什么来吓唬伊拉克人。今天节目有两个环节。第一部分，我们与巴格达郊外几英里处的国民警卫队员共度时光。第二部分，我们的杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）将与一位海军陆战队中尉聊聊费卢杰战役的真实情况，这位中尉指挥着查理连的一个排，而且恰好是他的侄子。请继续收听。
Act One, When Weekend Warriors Work Weekdays. Joe Betts signed up for the National Guard when he was 22. A friend was in the Guard, eight brothers in the Guard. He liked the military. At 42, he and his unit got called to service in Iraq. Joe had been working as an assistant minister in a Baptist church. And just two months before he got called up, he started his own church, which was progressing just fine.
第一部分：周末战士的工作日。乔·贝茨（Joe Betts）在22岁时加入了国民警卫队。当时他有个朋友在警卫队，他八个兄弟也都在警卫队，他喜欢军队。在42岁那年，他和他的部队被征召前往伊拉克服役。乔之前一直在一家浸信会教堂担任助理牧师。就在他被征召的前两个月，他还刚创办了自己的教会，一切进展得很顺利。
The attendance was good. We had about 30-plus people there each Sunday evening at 3:00. And I think it was going along pretty good.
出席率不错。每个周日晚上3点，我们大约有30多人。我认为一切都在向好发展。
We know that my unit, 239, has been called up to active duty. [INAUDIBLE] my strength in the Lord. I'm going through some hard times at this point in my life. It's a trying time. I need your prayers. I need your prayers. And I also would like to admonish the ones that have been attending services to continue to come. Continue to come. Don't stop. No matter what trials and tribulations come, he is telling us to press on.
我们得知我的部队，239部队，已被征召执行现役任务。[听不清]主是我的力量。我生命中现在经历着一些艰难时刻。这是一个考验的时期。我需要你们的祈祷。我需要你们的祈祷。我也想劝告那些一直参加礼拜的人，要继续来。继续来。不要停止。无论经历什么试炼和磨难，他都在告诉我们要坚持下去。
Hey, Joe, when you signed up for the Guard, did you ever think that you would be deployed?
嘿，乔，当你加入警卫队时，你有没有想过自己会被部署？
Yes.
想过。
You did?
真的吗？
I did. But for me to go, they had to reenlist me. Because my enlistment was actually about up. My 20 years would have been over with. My enlistment period actually was over before we were sent. And so they involuntarily gave me another year.
想过。但为了让我去，他们不得不让我重新入伍。因为我的服役期实际上快满了。我的20年服役期本来就要结束了。我的服役期在我们被派去之前实际上已经结束了。所以他们强制性地让我又服役了一年。
And if they had asked you whether or not you wanted to do that, would you have said that you wanted to do it, or that you wouldn't have wanted to do it?
如果他们问你是否愿意这样做，你会说你想去，还是说不想去？
At the time, I wouldn't have done it. I've had 20 years. And I felt like 20 years is enough to give to your country. I feel like I've done my duties. I don't feel like I owe anybody anything. And no, I don't think I would have went, if they'd have gave me that choice.
当时的话，我不会去。我已经服役20年了。我觉得20年对国家来说已经足够了。我觉得我已经尽到了职责。我不觉得我亏欠谁什么。不，我不认为我会去，如果他们给我选择的话。
Joe is one of the people in this new documentary series that's airing on a cable channel you probably don't catch too often, the Discovery Times channel. Two brothers from Arkansas, Brent and Craig Renaud, decided to follow one group of Arkansas National Guardsmen and their families from the announcement of their deployment to the day that the town holds a big rally to send them off, and into Kuwait and Iraq. Three episodes have aired already.
乔是这部新纪录片系列中的人物之一，该系列在一个你可能不太常看的有线电视频道播出，即探索时代频道（Discovery Times）。来自阿肯色州的两位兄弟，布伦特和克雷格·雷诺（Brent and Craig Renaud），决定跟踪拍摄一组阿肯色国民警卫队员及其家属，从宣布部署那天，到小镇为他们举行欢送集会，再到他们前往科威特和伊拉克的过程。目前已经播出了三集。
The brothers are still out there filming. The unit is still there in Iraq. And because these guys have gotten to know these men and their families so well, living with them for months now, the brothers have witnessed and filmed all kinds of things that have never been documented anywhere else. 40% of the soldiers in Iraq are reservists, either from the Army Reserve or from the National Guard. What this means for Arkansas is the largest call-up of reservists since the Korean War, 2,800 soldiers. Craig and Brent followed the 57 guardsmen from the town of Clarksville, Arkansas. Here's Craig.
兄弟俩还在前线拍摄。部队仍然驻扎在伊拉克。由于这两人已经与这些士兵及其家人非常熟络，并在一起生活了几个月，他们见证并拍摄到了许多在其他任何地方从未记录过的内容。伊拉克40%的士兵是预备役人员，来自陆军预备役或国民警卫队。这对阿肯色州意味着自朝鲜战争以来最大规模的预备役征召，涉及2800名士兵。克雷格和布伦特跟踪拍摄了来自阿肯色州克拉克斯维尔镇的57名警卫队员。请听克雷格的讲述。
Clarksville is a town of 7,000 people. One of the reasons we chose Clarksville is the majority of the National Guard that's in Iraq right now comes from small, rural towns like Clarksville. A lot of people that join the National Guard there do it for an extra paycheck.
克拉克斯维尔是一个拥有7000人口的小镇。我们选择克拉克斯维尔的原因之一是，目前在伊拉克的国民警卫队大多数来自像克拉克斯维尔这样的小型农村城镇。很多加入当地国民警卫队的人是为了多挣一份工资。
What do most of these guys think they were signing up for?
这些人大多数认为自己加入是为了什么？
When they initially signed up, like anyone else who joins the National Guard, they think they're signing up for one weekend a month, and two weeks a year. After 9/11, obviously, that changed everything. But no one thought they were signing up for a deployment. They were signing up to hang out with their buddies one weekend a month, get to shoot guns and drive trucks around, but definitely not go fight in a war. And in the early episodes of Off to War, you see how taken aback they are.
当他们最初入伍时，和任何加入国民警卫队的人一样，他们认为自己只是参加“一个月一个周末，一年两周”的训练。9/11事件后，情况显然改变了。但没人认为自己是去参加部署。他们加入是为了一个月一个周末和伙伴们聚在一起，练习射击和开开卡车，但绝对不是去打仗。在《奔赴战场》（Off to War）的早期剧集中，你可以看到他们是多么的措手不及。
We are out in the middle of the desert in Kuwait, eating a meal that came out of a brown plastic sack on probably the most expensive camping trip America has ever seen.
我们身处科威特的沙漠中央，吃着从褐色塑料袋里取出来的饭，这可能是美国历史上举办过的最昂贵的露营之旅。
This is my response to the National Guards. What happened to one weekend a month, two weeks a year?
这是我对国民警卫队的回答。说好的“一个月一个周末，一年两周”去哪了？
This is Matt Hertlein and his friend Tommy. Matt signed up for the Guard because he wanted free college and extra money on the weekends, and because Tommy made it sound like it would be a good time.
这是马特·赫特莱恩（Matt Hertlein）和他的朋友汤米。马特加入警卫队是因为他想要免费上大学和周末赚外快，而且因为汤米说这会很有趣。
The man I am today is because of that [BLEEP] right there. He is the one that I said, yeah, man, join the National Guard. Get drunk on the weekends and go to drills, and we can have all kinds of fun in college, partying. Yeah. Yeah.
我现在这副样子都是因为那个混蛋。是他对我说，嘿，伙计，加入国民警卫队吧。周末喝喝酒，去参加训练，我们在大学里可以尽情狂欢。是的。是的。
I see how much fun you're having in college.
我看到了你在大学里过得有多开心。
When's the last time you signed up for registration?
你最后一次注册（大学课程）是什么时候？
Well, Matt Hertlein and Tommy Erp, the 19-year-olds who joined, coming out of high school, they've talked about there's not a whole lot of opportunities for them. Matt even made the comment that if I wasn't here with all of my buddies in Iraq, I don't know what else I'd be doing. Because one, everybody's in the National Guard that I know, and so they're here. And if I was back home, there's not a lot of opportunity for us. When we were at a party, their last party that they went to, just before they left, all of their friends were joking about how they couldn't wait for their friends to leave, because now there would be more jobs available that they could get, once they were in Iraq.
马特·赫特莱恩和汤米·厄普（Tommy Erp）是19岁的年轻人，刚高中毕业就加入了。他们谈到自己其实没有太多机会。马特甚至评论说，如果我不在这里和我的伙伴们在伊拉克，我不知道我还能做什么。因为我认识的每个人都在国民警卫队，所以他们都在这儿。如果我回到家，我们也没有什么好机会。当我们在参加他们出发前的最后一次派对时，他们所有的朋友都在开玩笑说，他们迫不及待地希望他们快点走，因为这样等他们去了伊拉克，就会有更多的工作机会空出来了。
At the very beginning of the documentary, before they're sent out, Matt and Tommy are the only ones who actually seem to kind of look forward to going to Iraq. They're younger than the other Guardsmen, didn't have responsibilities at home, and didn't know much about what was going on the war. Sitting on the couch in Matt's house with some family, they talked about it.
在纪录片的最开始，在他们被派走之前，马特和汤米是仅有的几个看起来似乎有点期待去伊拉克的人。他们比其他警卫队员年轻，在家没有责任，对战争中发生的事情也不太了解。坐在马特家里的沙发上，和一些家人在一起时，他们谈到了这一点。
It's an opportunity to me. We can go over there and get the job done. And I think it'll be fun. I'll try to make the most of it. I think I'll have fun.
这对我来说是一个机会。我们可以去那边完成任务。我想这会很有趣。我会尽量充分利用它。我想我会玩得很开心。
Friends are going. I've got family going. Going to be pretty fun.
朋友们要去，我有家人也要去。会很有趣的。
My mom's not too happy about it. She's-- yeah. Every time she even starts talking about it, she starts bawling, man.
我妈对此不太高兴。她……是的。每次她开始谈论这件事，她就开始嚎啕大哭，伙计。
He's 19 years old. He just turned 19.
他才19岁。他刚满19岁。
We know what we're doing. It's not like we're going over there, and we're just going to be sandbags getting shot at. We know what we're doing. And we know how to control ourself.
我们知道自己在做什么。这可不是说我们去那边，就只是当当沙袋等着挨枪子。我们知道自己在做什么。而且我们知道如何控制自己。
Those suicide bombers and stuff, they're willing to kill their self, and they don't care who they kill.
那些自杀式炸弹袭击者之类的，他们愿意牺牲自己，他们根本不在乎会害死谁。
If I got to shoot somebody, I want to shoot them. I don't want to. It's not like I just want to go over there just to shoot people. But if I have to shoot somebody, I'm going to do it.
如果我必须开枪射杀某人，我会开枪。我不想那样。并不是说我只想去那边射杀平民。但如果我必须这么做，我会做的。
I just don't know if he realizes how dangerous it's going to be.
我只是不知道他是否意识到那会有多危险。
The Renaud brothers helped arrange for me to talk with Matt Hertlein from Camp Cooke, where he and his unit are stationed, in Taji, just a few miles north of Baghdad.
雷诺兄弟帮我安排了与驻扎在巴格达以北几英里处塔吉（Taji）库克营地的马特·赫特莱恩对话。
When you see that early footage of yourself saying, oh, it's going to be kind of fun. It'll be an adventure. Do you feel like, man, you don't even know what you're in for?
当你看到早期的影像中你自己说“噢，这会很有趣，这会是一次冒险”时，你会觉得“伙计，你根本不知道等待你的是什么”吗？
Oh yeah. It doesn't even seem like me saying it anymore. Just have been here for nine months, and then you watch that scene from that episode, and doesn't even-- I don't know. It's like I'm not even watching myself.
噢，是的。那听起来甚至不像是我说的话了。在这里待了九个月，再看那一集的片段，感觉……我不知道。就像我甚至不是在看我自己一样。
In the documentary, after the Arkansas Guardsmen are called up, but before they're shipped to Iraq, they're sent to training for six months at Fort Hood in Texas and Fort Polk in Louisiana. And seeing the footage of what they're like in training, the reality hits you, I think, of what it means that 40% of our forces in Iraq are reservists. Most of these are middle-aged guys who never thought that they would be deployed. In fact, some of them had served in the Army, and then switched to the Guard, specifically so they could get a pension without being deployed overseas. And so you notice something right away about their physical condition.
在纪录片中，当阿肯色州国民警卫队被征召后，在被派往伊拉克之前，他们被送往德克萨斯州的胡德堡（Fort Hood）和路易斯安那州的波尔克堡（Fort Polk）进行了六个月的训练。看到他们训练时的样子，我觉得你会意识到，40%的驻伊美军是预备役人员意味着什么。这些人大多数是中年人，从未想过自己会被部署。事实上，他们中有些人曾在陆军服役，后来转入警卫队，就是为了不用被派往海外也能获得养老金。所以你很快就会注意到他们身体状况的一点。
I think like most people in America, a lot of these guys were out of shape.
我想像美国的大多数人一样，这些家伙中很多人的身体状况都很糟糕。
Filmmaker Brent Renaud.
电影制作人布伦特·雷诺。
Remember, they were only doing one weekend a month, two weeks a year. They weren't expected to be in war shape, in combat shape. And like the rest of America, a lot of them were not in that shape.
记住，他们以前只是“一个月一个周末，一年两周”。没人指望他们保持战备状态、战斗体能。和美国其他人一样，他们很多人并没有那种体能。
Here, get a shot of my big belly. Here you go. That'll be gone about the time I get home.
来，拍一下我的大肚子。给你。等我回家的时候这玩意儿就没了。
Come on, blow the whistle.
快点，吹哨啊。
Imagine being sent back to junior high school gym class as an adult, and you get the picture of what's happening here, a bunch of homeowners and parents in gym shorts and t-shirts, jumping up and down in a row, most of them with these looks on the faces like they cannot believe this is happening to them.
想象一下，成年后再被送回初中体育课，你就明白了这里正在发生什么：一群房主和父亲穿着运动短裤和T恤，排成一排跳上跳下，大多数人脸上的表情仿佛是不敢相信这居然发生在他们身上。
[WHISTLE]
[哨声]
One soldier asks if he can smoke during calisthenics. When they do situps, another guy barely picks his shoulders up off the ground.
一名士兵在做健身操时问能不能抽烟。做仰卧起坐时，另一个人几乎连肩膀都离不开地面。
Aw, [BLEEP], situps. Aw, [BLEEP].
噢，该死，仰卧起坐。噢，该死。
[WHISTLE]
[哨声]
Told to run in a circle, one soldier takes off in the wrong direction completely.
被命令绕圈跑时，一名士兵完全跑错了方向。
Clockwise. Clockwise. Think of a clock, clockwise.
顺时针。顺时针。想一想时钟，顺时针。
And when they're put into formation and ordered to march, this is what happens.
当他们被编队并命令齐步走时，发生了这样的事。
Mark time, march.
原地踏步，走。
[CONFUSED MUTTERING]
[困惑的嘟囔声]
Half of them just look around. One guy scratches his jock. It's momentary chaos. And then they start over.
一半人只是在那儿左顾右盼。一个人在那儿挠他的护裆。那一刻简直是一片混乱。然后他们重头开始。
Lock and load.
上膛准备。
Even on the shooting range, there's a Bad News Bears quality to these early scenes.
即使在射击场上，这些早期的场景也有种《少棒闯天下》（Bad News Bears）的味道。
[GUNFIRE]
[枪声]
You fired three rounds. Three rounds. How many holes do you see? [BLEEP]
你打了三发子弹。三发。你看到几个弹孔？该死。
This is going to be a lot different than just hunting back home.
这跟在老家打猎可大不相同。
Sergeant Joe Betts, the minister who was re-enlisted against his will, who was in his 40s, remember, as he went through all this training, says he was overweight by official Army standards, but was still able to do all the pushups and situps and running required by the Army.
乔·贝茨中士，就是那位被违背意愿重新入伍的牧师，请记住，他当时40多岁。当他经历这一切训练时，他说按照陆军的官方标准，他虽然超重，但仍然能够完成陆军要求的所有俯卧撑、仰卧起坐和跑步。
In the film, Joe, early on, you say this, that a lot of the guys weren't taking the training seriously enough.
在片中，乔，在早期你曾说，很多队员没有认真对待训练。
Right.
没错。
What did you see that made you say that? What was happening?
你看到了什么让你这么说？发生了什么？
The laughter. When we were training, you would see people just sitting around, saying, aw, man, this is not going to happen over there. This is not what's going to happen.
笑声。当我们训练时，你会看到人们只是坐在那儿说，噢，伙计，在那边不会发生这种事。这不是会发生的情况。
Welcome to Fort Hood. This stuff is pretty simple from here on out.
欢迎来到胡德堡。从这儿开始，事情就很简单了。
It's night. Dozens of Arkansas Guardsmen in formation, at attention, staring forward. They've just arrived at this base in Texas.
那是夜晚。几十名阿肯色州国民警卫队员排成队列，立正站好，目视前方。他们刚抵达这个德克萨斯州的基地。
All you have to do is be where you are supposed to be when you're supposed to be there. And everything else is a cakewalk. Hoo-ah? All right. That's all I got. Oh, and turn them stupid cell phones off when you're standing in formation. Got it? Thank you.
你们所要做的就是：在要求的时间出现在要求的地方。剩下的都是小菜一碟。听明白了吗？好的。我就说这些。噢，还有，列队的时候把那些愚蠢的手机关掉。听到了吗？谢谢。
That's Brian Mason. He was brought in from a different unit to bring leadership to the engineer unit.
那是布莱恩·梅森（Brian Mason）。他被从其他单位调过来，为工程单位带来领导力。
Again, filmmaker Craig Renaud.
再次邀请电影制作人克雷格·雷诺。
And when he did notice, maybe, some people being a little more lackadaisical than they could, I think the responsibility started weighing on him that he's got to get these guys home alive. He had been in Desert Storm. He didn't want anyone to die on his watch. He says a lot. You see him saying speeches. You guys got to get your game face on, you got to get your game face on.
当他确实注意到有些人可能比他们应有的表现更懒散时，我想责任感开始压在他身上了，他必须让这些人活着回家。他曾参加过“沙漠风暴”行动。他不希望在他监督下有人死亡。他经常这样说。你可以看到他在发表讲话。你们必须拿出战斗状态来，你们必须拿出战斗状态来。
Company [? a-ten-tion.
连……立正。
This is in their barracks, guys on benches, lockers, everywhere. They stand in a tired sort of way. One guy stands on his bed.
这是在他们的兵营里，到处都是长凳、储物柜。他们以一种疲惫的姿态站着。一个人站在他的床上。
I want to thank each and every one of you for embarrassing the [BLEEP] out of me with this sad display of disrespect. Get down off those bunks. Stand at ease.
我要感谢你们每一个人，以这种可悲的、缺乏尊重的表现让我丢尽了脸。从那些铺位上下来。稍息。
A colonel, lieutenant colonel just walked into this company, walked past 20, 30 people, probably. Not one of you called the room to attention. Not one of you said, sir. Who the hell do you people think you are? Hell, half of you don't even salute me when I'm outside, or the other platoon leaders, or the company commander.
一位中校刚走进这个连队，可能走过了20、30个人身边。没有一个人叫全连立正。没有一个人喊“长官”。你们这群人到底以为自己是谁？见鬼，甚至当我或排长、连长在外面时，你们中有一半人连个军礼都不敬。
Who they are, of course, is grown men, mostly, not career military, not young recruits. And it's strange to watch them get chewed out like teenagers. They stare ahead, faces blank.
当然，他们都是成年人，大多不是职业军人，也不是年轻的新兵。看着他们像青少年一样被训斥，真是很奇怪。他们盯着前方，面无表情。
You want to make life hard for yourself? Keep that [BLEEP] up. First Sergeant, they're all yours. Take care of them.
你们想让日子难过吗？那就继续那样做。第一中士，他们归你了。好好照顾他们。
The 39th Brigade went through three weeks of combat training at Fort Polk, Louisiana, part of a joint readiness program. This was the army's attempt to simulate, as best as it could, what operations would be like in Iraq. Again, filmmaker Craig Renaud.
第39旅在路易斯安那州波尔克堡进行了为期三周的战斗训练，这是联合战备计划的一部分。这是陆军试图尽可能模拟伊拉克行动情况的尝试。同样，电影制作人克雷格·雷诺。
And the idea was, they brought in a lot of Iraqis, mostly Kurdish Iraqis who live in the United States, to do a lot of role-playing. And they would speak only in Arabic to the soldiers. And they would have to undergo things like you would do in a peace and stability operation.
他们的想法是，带入大量伊拉克人，主要是居住在美国的库尔德伊拉克人，来做大量的角色扮演。他们只对士兵说阿拉伯语。他们必须经历那些在和平与稳定行动中会遇到的事情。
They did one training exercise where they had to go on a convoy through a town. And as they came into the town, there was a protest of Iraqis. And they had to come in and ask the Iraqis if they could pass their convoy through. And what it turned out is that the Iraqis were actually protesting a rise in the meat prices, but the soldiers assumed that they were protesting the American presidency.
他们做了一次训练演习，必须乘车队穿过一个小镇。当他们进入小镇时，那里有一场伊拉克人的抗议。他们必须进去询问伊拉克人是否可以让他们的车队通过。结果发现，伊拉克人实际上是在抗议肉价上涨，但士兵们假设他们是在抗议美国总统。
[GUNSHOT]
[枪声]
[YELLING]
[叫喊声]
Anyway, the way they handled it escalated the situation. And the commander ended up getting killed.
无论如何，他们处理这件事的方式使局势升级了。最终指挥官被击毙了。
Take that two right there. [INAUDIBLE], stay where you're at. [INAUDIBLE], stay where you're at. Hold your weapons to your right.
那儿那两个带走。[听不清]，待在你所在的位置。[听不清]，待在你所在的位置。把武器举到右侧。
An industrial-sized smoke machine, who knew the Army owns an industrial-sized smoke machine, billows white smoke. People scatter everywhere. Civilians in headscarves wail over their fake dead. Officers and trainers stroll through the melee, observing and saying things like, well, I guess that'll teach them not to leave their vehicles unattended.
一台工业级烟雾机——谁能想到陆军拥有工业级烟雾机——喷出了白色的烟雾。人们四散奔逃。戴着头巾的平民在他们假装死去的同伴身上哀嚎。军官和教练在混乱中走来走去，观察并说着诸如“好吧，我想这能教会他们不要让车辆无人看管”之类的话。
Incoming!
有敌袭！
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
I wish we could have had a little more training, to be honest.
说实话，我希望我们能多进行一些训练。
Again, 19-year-old Matt Hertlein, talking with me from outside Baghdad.
还是19岁的马特·赫特莱恩，在巴格达外与我交谈。
I don't think we got enough.
我觉得我们训练得不够。
How well-prepared were you for what you're doing now every day?
你现在每天所做的事情，你觉得你准备得有多充分？
Oh. Actually, we weren't really prepared it all. We were prepared for going up and down the road and things like that. But the kinds of missions that we've been doing over here, that's not the kind of thing that we trained for. It's not even close. They don't compare at all.
噢。实际上，我们根本没有准备好。我们只为在路上行驶之类的任务做了准备。但我们在这里执行的任务类型，根本不是我们训练的那些。甚至完全不是那么回事。根本无法相比。
The people that trained us, you've got to understand, even if they had been over here, it was for Desert Storm, which was a completely different war than what we're fighting here.
你得明白，那些训练我们的人，即便他们曾来过这里，那也是为了“沙漠风暴”行动，那和我们现在打的这场战争完全不同。
Sergeant David Short is a policeman in civilian life. In Iraq, he commands a combat unit in the Arkansas National Guard. He's another person in the film who spoke with me from Taji, outside Baghdad.
大卫·肖特（David Short）中士在平民生活中是一名警察。在伊拉克，他指挥着阿肯色州国民警卫队的一个战斗单位。他也是片中在巴格达外的塔吉与我交谈的人。
The people that did the training actually did the best that they knew to do. They were under the impression that the war was over, and that we would basically be doing security and stability operations, where we were just in the rebuilding phase of the country. Because they figured the major combat was over. And when we got here, that's not really what happened. We immediately started combat patrols. In fact, the second day that I was here, we were given a photocopy of a piece of a map and directions to a gate, and told to go out and start patrolling, looking for insurgents.
那些负责训练的人确实尽了他们所知最好的努力。他们当时以为战争已经结束了，我们基本上会执行安全和稳定行动，处于国家的重建阶段。因为他们以为主要的战斗已经结束了。当我们到达时，情况并非如此。我们立即开始了战斗巡逻。事实上，我来这里的第二天，我们就收到了一张复印的地图碎片和去往某个关口的指示，然后被要求出发去开始巡逻，寻找叛乱分子。
Sergeant Short and Matt Hertlein both told me they wish that they'd had more regular combat training, how to patrol, how fire weapons from different positions, how to capture and detain people. Part of the problem is just a coincidence in timing. The 39th Battalion arrived in-country in April 2004. Here's Brent Renaud.
肖特中士和马特·赫特莱恩都告诉我，他们希望曾接受过更多正规的战斗训练：如何巡逻、如何从不同位置射击、如何俘虏和拘留人员。问题的一部分仅仅是时机巧合。第39营于2004年4月抵达伊拉克。布伦特·雷诺说：
And if you remember, April of last year is when the security situation really started to deteriorate in Iraq. That's when Fallujah really started to take place. And--
如果你记得的话，去年四月，伊拉克的安全局势确实开始恶化。那就是费卢杰战役真正开始的时候。而且——
That's the month that they captured those private contractors and killed them and hung them from that bridge. That's when it really all changed.
那正是他们抓获并杀害那些私人承包商，并将他们悬挂在桥上的那个月。那就是一切真正改变的时候。
Exactly. That happened the day before we pulled out of Kuwait to convoy into Iraq.
没错。那件事发生在我们离开科威特前往伊拉克的头一天。
They started doing things like going on patrols, looking for roadside bombs, guarding prisoners. These sort of things that they weren't trained for, because nobody envisioned that they would actually be doing them in Iraq.
他们开始执行诸如巡逻、寻找路边炸弹、看守囚犯等任务。这些他们未受过训练的事情，因为没人预料到他们真的会在伊拉克做这些。
One simple but important piece of training that they lacked: what to do if their vehicles rolled across an IED, an Improvised Explosive Device. Back before they arrived in Iraq, IED explosions were much less common than they are these days. Now they're so frequent that Sergeant Short's unit has been blown up two dozen times by IEDs. Three of those times, Sergeant Short himself was in the convoy.
他们缺乏的一项简单但重要的训练是：当车辆轧过简易爆炸装置（IED）时该怎么办。在他们到达伊拉克之前，IED爆炸事件远比现在罕见。现在它们太频繁了，以至于肖特中士的部队已经被IED炸了两次以上。其中三次，肖特中士本人就在车队里。
And the thing that a lot of people, that I didn't know, until I'd actually been in one and got hit, is your radio is no good to you for about 10 seconds. So you may be trying to talk to somebody, but the explosion creates blast waves that interfere with the radio waves. And your communication equipment is no good for approximately 10 to 15 seconds. So it's imperative that everybody pay attention to what everybody else is doing. If you hear the explosion, you need to be looking to make sure everybody that's supposed to be with you is with you. So if for any reason you need to turn around and go back and pick somebody up or recover their vehicle, you can. But these are things we learned ourselves.
很多人不知道、直到我真的遇袭过才知道的一件事是，在最初的10秒左右，你的电台对你毫无用处。所以你可能正试图和某人通话，但爆炸产生的冲击波干扰了无线电波。你的通讯设备大约有10到15秒的时间无法使用。所以，每个人都必须留意其他人正在做什么，这至关重要。如果你听到爆炸声，你需要环顾四周，确保所有应该和你在一起的人都在。这样如果有任何原因需要你掉头回去接某人或收回车辆，你就能做到。但这些都是我们自己学到的。
And so you didn't actually do drills on what to do if you're in a vehicle in a convoy and an IED goes off? That's not something you practiced for.
所以你们实际上并没有进行过如果车辆在车队中遭遇IED爆炸该怎么办的演习？那不是你们练习过的东西？
No, no. We just learned the hard way on those. The first time we had an actual Improvised Explosive Device go off, it disabled the truck. They were ambushed. One of the guys was killed.
不，不。我们在那些事情上只能吃一堑长一智。我们第一次遇到真正的简易爆炸装置爆炸时，车辆损坏了。他们遭到了伏击。其中一人被杀了。
They did train us. They did give us the standard procedure of what they wanted us to do. We followed those procedures.
他们确实训练过我们。他们确实给出了标准的程序，说明他们希望我们怎么做。我们遵循了这些程序。
And basically, what happened is a truck got left by itself with no combat support, because they did what they were trained to do, push forward 300 meters, and then assess the situation. Well, they had a truck that was disabled, and they pushed out 300 meters and left it there. And so those guys are in a firefight, fighting for their lives, and then they guys say, oh, we got to go back and get them. And then we got back, and the leaders all sat together and said, we did what we were trained to do. But it doesn't work.
基本情况是，由于他们做了他们受训要做的事——向前推进300米，然后评估情况——导致一辆卡车被遗落在原地，没有任何战斗支援。好吧，他们有一辆损坏的卡车，他们推进到了300米外，把它扔在那里。于是那些人陷入了交火，为生命而战，然后大家说，噢，我们得回去救他们。然后我们回去了，领导们坐在一起说，我们做了受训要做的事。但那没用。
And how could they have trained you to prepare for those?
他们本该如何训练你们来应对这些？
Well, to be honest, really, in their defense, it would be very difficult for them to train us for something that they had no personal experience with. By the time they finally do go to Iraq, the guys have lost weight. In-country, they lose even more, wearing 60-pound vests all day in a place that gets up to 120 degrees. And some of the most disturbing moments in the film have to do with the equipment that they take with them, vehicles that the Arkansas National Guard's had for years, decades.
说实话，平心而论，要训练我们应对他们自己都没有个人经验的事情是非常困难的。等他们最终前往伊拉克时，队员们已经减重了。在伊拉克境内，他们损失更多，整天穿着60磅重的背心，在气温高达120度的地方。片中最令人不安的时刻与他们随身携带的设备有关：阿肯色州国民警卫队使用了多年甚至数十年的车辆。
So these five ton dump trucks, the youngest one we have is 1956. The newest one we have is 1964.
所以这些五吨重的自卸卡车，我们这里最年轻的也是1956年的。最新的也是1964年的。
Only 4 of the unit's 42 vehicles were properly armored. Again, filmmaker Craig Renaud.
该单位42辆车中只有4辆有合适的装甲。电影制作人克雷格·雷诺再次说道。
And brigade-wide, I think this is pretty representative in terms of the armor situation that they had. The vehicle that I convoyed in into Iraq, I was in the a back of a vehicle that had a pine box around it with sandbags in the middle of it. And they said that they hoped that they might slow the bullets down. They didn't have any hopes that it would actually stop a bullet, but it might actually slow it down and reduce the damage that it would do to you. So it certainly wasn't comforting to be convoying into Iraq in those type of vehicles.
就整个旅而言，我认为这在他们拥有的装甲状况方面非常有代表性。我乘坐进入伊拉克的车辆，是在一辆车的后部，它周围有一个松木箱，中间装满了沙袋。他们说希望这能减慢子弹的速度。他们并不指望这真的能挡住子弹，但它可能确实能减慢速度，减少对你造成的伤害。所以乘坐这种车辆进入伊拉克肯定让人无法感到安心。
We were promised up-armor kits. We didn't get them. And so we're going to go ahead and try to fabricate something.
我们被承诺提供附加装甲套件。我们没得到。所以我们要继续尝试自己制造一些东西。
Thank you sir.
谢谢长官。
You think we could use some of this stuff?
你觉得我们能用这些东西吗？
Yeah, let's take that with us.
是的，我们带上它。
What follows next is soldiers in the most powerful army in the history of man scrounging in scrap heaps for sheets of iron to weld to the doors and floorboards of their own vehicles.
接下来发生的是，人类历史上最强大军队的士兵们在废料堆里搜寻铁皮，焊接在自己车辆的车门和地板上。
We're trying to use as much of the metal as we can, of the steel. But we only have a limited supply of it. So we have to resort to these old bulletproof vests. And honestly, I don't feel too comfortable with doing that. But we've got to do what we've got to do, man. We've got to use what we can.
我们正尽量多地使用钢材。但我们只有有限的供应。所以我们不得不求助于这些旧的防弹背心。老实说，我做这件事并不感到舒服。但我们必须做我们必须做的事，伙计。我们得用我们能用的任何东西。
That's Matt Hertlein attaching the old armored vest to his truck door for protection. When I asked him about this moment in the documentary, he told me--
那是马特·赫特莱恩把旧的防弹背心贴在他的卡车门上以求保护。当我在纪录片中问他关于那一刻时，他告诉我——
It was like a scene out of The A-Team.
那就像《天龙特攻队》（The A-Team）里的场景。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I think we're just on the bottom of the list. Priority goes to the regular Army, and the Marine Corps, and whoever else. We just get whatever's left over.
我觉得我们只是排在名单的最底部。优先级属于正规陆军、海军陆战队以及其他任何人。我们只能得到剩下的任何东西。
It takes three months for the 3,000 person brigade to get armor and all the vehicles that need it. They still have some un-armored vehicles. But those usually don't leave the base. Other reservists who have been there less time are not as far along in getting the armor that they need. And the Army Times reported last month that it will be June before all the trucks and Humvees in Iraq all have proper armor. A third still lack it, 11,000 vehicles. Again, here's Sergeant Joe Betts, the 42-year-old minister that we started our story with.
这个3000人的旅花了三个月才获得装甲和所有需要它的车辆。他们仍然有一些无装甲车辆。但那些车通常不离开基地。其他驻扎时间较短的预备役人员在获得所需装甲方面进度没那么快。《陆军时报》（Army Times）上个月报道称，直到六月，伊拉克所有的卡车和悍马车才会拥有合适的装甲。仍有三分之一，即11000辆车缺乏装甲。再次请出乔·贝茨中士，就是我们故事开头那位42岁的牧师。
We wasn't armored the way we should have been armored going into Iraq.
我们进入伊拉克时并没有像我们应该有的那样装备装甲。
And did that make everybody mad? Were you mad?
这让每个人都愤怒了吗？你生气吗？
Of course that make people mad.
当然会让人们生气。
Now over a half a year after all that, in December, National Guardsmen from Tennessee brought up this exact problem with Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld in this town meeting they held over there.
现在在半年多后的12月，田纳西州的国民警卫队员在伊拉克举行的市政厅会议上向国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德提出了这个确切的问题。
Exactly. And I did see that.
没错。我确实看到了。
Now, Secretary of Defense Rumsfeld said that they're getting out the armored vehicles as quickly as they can. And he said, you go to war with the army you have, not the army you want. What do you think of that?
现在，国防部长拉姆斯菲尔德说，他们正尽可能快地调拨装甲车辆。他说，你只能带着你现有的军队去打仗，而不是你想要的军队。你对此怎么看？
Well, actually, that is true. You do go to war with the army you have. But prior to us going to war, they knew we was going. They had already talked about us going. So why didn't they do something about the up-armament that we needed prior to going to war?
好吧，事实上，那是真的。你确实只能带着你现有的军队去打仗。但在我们去打仗之前，他们知道我们要去。他们已经谈论过我们要去的事了。那么为什么在去打仗之前，他们不对我们所需的装甲防护做些什么呢？
But they didn't anticipate that there were going to be these insurgents at this level. They didn't necessarily know that there was going to be a need for it.
但他们没预料到会有这种程度的叛乱分子。他们不一定知道会有这个需求。
Oh yeah. Any time you go to war, you need armor. So that's not something that even in World War I, II, they knew they needed armor. You don't go to war thinking that you're going to go out there with no armor on, and you're not going to get hurt. So to me, for them to just send us over there and say that you don't need this gear, you don't need this up-armor on your vehicles is saying that I don't care about the soldiers. That's what it says to me.
噢，是的。无论何时你去打仗，你都需要装甲。所以这不是说，即使在第一次、第二次世界大战中，他们也知道他们需要装甲。你不会带着“没装甲也没事，我不会受伤”的想法去打仗。所以对我来说，他们只是把我们派过去，说你不需要这种装备，你的车辆不需要这种加固装甲，就是在说我不关心士兵。这就是它对我的意义。
The day they actually drive from Kuwait into Iraq, things change for the Arkansas brigade, in a number of ways.
他们真正开车从科威特进入伊拉克的日子，对阿肯色州旅来说在许多方面发生了改变。
Today's the day. This is our first interaction with the Iraqis. Be polite, be professional, and be prepared to kill. We're in transition phase right now. We go from the training, the game, to the Super Bowl, to the war.
今天是这一天。这是我们与伊拉克人的第一次互动。要礼貌，要专业，并准备好杀戮。我们现在正处于过渡阶段。我们从训练、热身赛，变成了超级碗，变成了战争。
This is Lieutenant Brian Mason, who you heard earlier yelling at guys. Now they're sitting on bunks, listening, attentive, worried-looking.
这是布莱恩·梅森中尉，你之前听过他对着队员大喊大叫。现在他们坐在铺位上，听着，专注着，表情忧虑。
So you guys need to put on your game face, right here, right now. These Iraqis, they know who we are. They know you're National Guardsmen. Yeah, they're going to target you, because they think you're just a bunch of lazy, fat National Guardsmen who don't know how to do their job.
所以你们需要拿出战斗状态来，就在这儿，现在。这些伊拉克人，他们知道我们是谁。他们知道你们是国民警卫队员。是的，他们会针对你们，因为他们认为你们只是一群懒惰、肥胖的国民警卫队员，根本不知道怎么干活。
Welcome to Baghdad. Keep your eyes open.
欢迎来到巴格达。睁大眼睛。
This is Joe, the minister, in a convoy into Iraq.
这是乔，那位牧师，在进入伊拉克的车队里。
I've been here for about 10 minutes, and I already know I hate Baghdad. I hate the country. I don't want to be here.
我来这儿大约10分钟了，我已经知道我讨厌巴格达。我讨厌这个国家。我不想待在这里。
I hear that.
我听到了。
Hertlein, just got a mortar round fired. A mortar round was just fired. Welcome home, guys. Camp Cooke. 1 day down, 364 days to go.
赫特莱恩，刚有迫击炮弹射过来。刚刚发射了一枚迫击炮弹。欢迎回家，伙计们。库克营地。第一天过去，还剩364天。
Filmmaker Craig Renaud.
电影制作人克雷格·雷诺。
Well, the very first day that this brigade arrived to the base, there was an Arkansas National Guard soldier killed within the first 10 hours. A mortar came in. I would say as a whole, that's where you really saw people realize that this is for real.
嗯，这个旅抵达基地的第一天，就有阿肯色州国民警卫队士兵在10小时内被杀。一枚迫击炮弹打进来了。总的来说，我想那就是你真正看到人们意识到这事是来真的地方。
Of course, my unit, unfortunately, took the first National Guard casualty from the entire brigade.
当然，我的部队，不幸的是，承受了整个旅的第一名国民警卫队伤亡。
Again, Sergeant David Short, who commands a combat unit, talking to me from Iraq.
再次邀请大卫·肖特中士，他指挥着一个战斗单位，从伊拉克与我交谈。
And we had been here one day. We got hit with a rocket attack, and it killed Sergeant Labadie, and it seriously wounded Sergeant [? Leisure. ?]
我们已经在这儿一天了。我们遭到了火箭袭击，拉巴迪（Labadie）中士被炸死，莱瑟（Leisure）中士受了重伤。
The thing about a brigade like this with the Arkansas National Guard, all those guys that we were following knew that first soldier that was killed. And the minute he was killed, everybody's demeanor changed, and everybody knew this was for real. I don't know. At least in the unit we were with, it seemed like a lot of guys weren't taking it that seriously until that happened. Two days later, another soldier was killed. I happened to be at the motor pool when they brought that vehicle back in. I saw the medic get out, completely covered in blood.
像阿肯色国民警卫队这样的旅，我们跟踪的所有那些人都认识第一个被杀的士兵。就在他被杀的那一刻，每个人的风貌都变了，每个人都知道这是来真的。我不知道。至少在我们所在的部队中，在发生那件事之前，似乎很多队员并没有那么当回事。两天后，另一名士兵被杀了。我恰好在维修站时，他们把那辆车带了回来。我看到军医走下来，浑身是血。
Right. He got killed in an ambush of a Humvee.
没错。他在悍马车的伏击中被杀。
Exactly, in an ambush.
没错，在伏击中。
The windshield shattered when the IED went off. This was the last place that Sergeant Del Greco was.
IED爆炸时挡风玻璃粉碎了。这就是德尔格雷科（Del Greco）中士最后待的地方。
This is Sergeant Short in footage from the movie, standing in front of the shot-up vehicle with his men. Matt and Tommy are there, looking stunned, vulnerable.
这是肖特中士在电影片段中，站在破烂的车辆前对着部下说话。马特和汤米也在那儿，看起来震惊且脆弱。
I hope it gets real for you guys, I really do. Because this is very difficult for me. Because I love every one of these guys in this troop. And everybody means something. And we're all here. And there's nothing that we can do to change it.
我真的希望这对你们来说是来真的，我真的希望。因为这对我来说非常困难。因为我爱这个部队里的每一个人。每个人都有某种意义。我们都在这儿。而我们什么也改变不了。
It's not worth it. But we're here. And we got a mission to do. And we're going to keep doing it. I'm going to take it to them. I'm going to take the fight to them.
这不值得。但我们在这儿。我们有一个任务要完成。我们会继续做下去。我会把战争带给他们。我会把战争带给他们。
And I'm going to try to eradicate every one of these people that I can off of the face of the earth, because they've taken people of mine away from me. And I'll see that justice is done for them, for nobody else but ourselves. I just hope that everybody's prepared for it, because it's ugly out there.
而且我会尽量从地球表面根除这些人的每一个，因为他们夺走了我的人。我会确保为他们伸张正义，不为别人，只为我们自己。我只是希望每个人都做好了准备，因为外面很丑陋。
This footage in the documentary of you talking to your troops about it, they all look pretty shaken up as you're saying this stuff to them. Did some of them come and talk to you about it later?
纪录片中你对部下说这些话的镜头里，他们看起来都很震惊。后来有人来找你谈过吗？
Yeah. I had a lot of people come to me and say, look, what do I do? I'm terrified. I don't want to go outside here. I'm consumed with fear.
有。很多人来找我说，长官，我该怎么办？我很恐惧。我不想待在这里。恐惧吞噬了我。
I had one young man come to me and tell me that he had lost all his faith, that he was saved. His father was a pastor. He had been a Christian all his life. He said, I've lost my salvation. I can't deal with this. And so there was a lot of time spent talking to people, reassuring them, praying with them, praying for them.
有个年轻人来告诉我他失去了所有的信仰，他曾是得救的。他父亲是牧师。他一生都是基督徒。他说，我失去了救赎。我无法应付这个。所以花了很多时间与人们交谈，安慰他们，与他们一起祈祷，为他们祈祷。
Yeah, what do you say to somebody when they tell you something like that? What can help them?
是的，当有人告诉你这样的话时，你说什么？什么能帮助他们？
Well, the main thing that I had to do, and it was something that I had to reach deep down inside, was to show them that regardless of what happens, I was going to be there. We're going to go out there. We're going to do this together. I was going to be there.
嗯，我必须做的最主要的事情，是我必须从内心深处去挖掘的事情，那就是向他们表明，无论发生什么，我都会在那儿。我们会走出去。我们会一起做这件事。我会在那儿。
What happens next is that the guys turn it around. They totally step up to the jobs they were sent to do. They work well together. They look out for each other. Matt turns out to be one of the best gunners in the group. In 10 months, no other Guardsmen from Clarksville have died.
接下来发生的是，伙计们扭转了局面。他们完全胜任了被派来的工作。他们配合得很好。他们互相关照。马特成为了组里最好的炮手之一。在10个月里，没有其他来自克拉克斯维尔的国民警卫队员阵亡。
And people don't complain. There's barely any complaining anymore, unless something very unusual happens. Here's Craig and then Brent Renaud.
而且人们不再抱怨了。几乎没有任何抱怨，除非发生非常不寻常的事。请听克雷格和布伦特·雷诺。
As the deployment goes along, and as the film follows this deployment, they find out, just like the rest of the country did, things about 9/11 and the investigations that they were doing. There was actually a day when I was with them in Iraq, where the Stars and Stripes, which is the military newspaper that comes out, the front page was about the 9/11 panel commission, and the hearings, and there not being a link between Iraq and 9/11. And they were shocked when they read that.
随着部署的进行，随着影片跟踪这次部署，他们发现，就像全国其他人一样，关于9/11和他们正在进行的调查的事情。当我还在伊拉克和他们在一起时，确实有一天，《星条旗报》（Stars and Stripes），也就是发行的军事报纸，头版是关于9/11委员会和听证会的，以及没有证据表明伊拉克和9/11之间有联系。他们读到那个时非常震惊。
And what would they say? They're patriotic guys, so they're doing their duty and all that, want to support the President. But what's that do to them to see that?
他们会说什么？他们是爱国主义者，所以他们在尽职责，想支持总统。但看到那个对他们来说意味着什么？
Since then, I think, maybe, they wished they had toned it down a little bit. But at that particular time, they said, we're angry. We were fooled. And we feel betrayed. And we're over here, risking our lives, and it's not what we thought it was, and that people were dying for something that they weren't sure if it was going to accomplish anything.
从那以后，我想，也许他们希望他们当时能稍微淡化一点。但在那个特定时间，他们说，我们很愤怒。我们被愚弄了。我们感到被背叛了。我们在这里冒险，而这不是我们所想的那样，人们为了某些不确定是否能达成任何结果的事情而牺牲。
Throughout this whole documentary, the Arkansas Guardsmen show this mix of doubts about their mission and a willingness to suspend those doubts and follow orders. When I asked Matt if he's hopeful about the way things work out in Iraq, he says, sure, they're definitely trying to help people there. Even Joe, who thinks there was no reason to go to war in the first place, is convinced that God must have some plan, some good reason of his own for putting Americans in Iraq. Here's what Sergeant Short thinks.
在整个纪录片中，阿肯色国民警卫队展示了对任务的怀疑与服从命令的意愿的混合。当我问马特是否对伊拉克的局势抱有希望时，他说，当然，他们绝对是在努力帮助那里的人。即使是乔，那位起初认为根本没有理由去打仗的牧师，也确信上帝一定有什么计划，有他自己让美国人进入伊拉克的正当理由。肖特中士是这么想的。
I don't want to say that it's a lost cause, because I've lost good friends over here. And for me to say that would mean that they died for nothing. But it's very disheartening to me, because I work with the Iraqi National Guard. I've worked with the the new Iraqi Army. I've worked with the Iraqi police force.
我不想说这是一个注定失败的事业，因为我在这里失去了好朋友。如果我这么说，就意味着他们白白牺牲了。但这让我感到非常沮丧，因为我和伊拉克国民警卫队一起工作。我和新的伊拉克军队一起工作过。我和伊拉克警察部队一起工作过。
And you've got the three security forces for this country that are in no way on the same sheet of music. They do not like each other. They do not trust each other. And their heart's not in it. And a lot of times, it's just very frustrating, because they just don't seem to care, one way or another.
这个国家的这三支安全部队根本不在同一个频道上。他们不喜欢对方。他们互不信任。而且他们没有心思在这上面。很多时候，这真的很令人沮丧，因为他们看起来一点也不在乎。
Filmmaker Brent Renaud.
电影制作人布伦特·雷诺。
I was out with the armed patrol the other day, and one of the Iraqi translators, as we were going up and down the road, we were talking to the local people and asking them, who was putting these roadside bombs out into the road. And the locals said, it's the Americans putting them out there, because they're trying to destabilize our country. As we went along the road, person after person was saying this same thing, which is very upsetting to the soldiers, because people in their unit had been killed by the roadside bombs.
前几天我跟着武装巡逻队出去，其中一名伊拉克翻译，当我们沿着路行驶时，我们和当地人交谈，问他们是谁把这些路边炸弹放在路上。当地人说，是美国人放的，因为他们想破坏我们国家的稳定。我们沿着路走，一个人接一个人都在说同样的话，这让士兵们非常难过，因为他们单位里有人已经被路边炸弹炸死了。
Joe Betts, the minister, says that being in Iraq has made him question his faith many times. He talks openly in the film about how the deployment is ruining his life, causing trouble in his marriage. Before he left for Iraq, he had some problems with neck, muscle spasms that were aggravated by all the weight that they were constantly carrying around in the military. Then a month into his deployment, he got this tingling and numbness in his arms and his fingers. It reached a point where he couldn't hold up his gun. And doctors said that a disc in his spine was out of place.
乔·贝茨牧师说，身在伊拉克使他多次质疑自己的信仰。他在片中公开谈论了部署是如何摧毁了他的生活，导致了他的婚姻危机。在他去伊拉克之前，他有一些颈部和肌肉痉挛的问题，因为他在军队中总是背负着沉重的负担而加剧。在部署一个月后，他的手臂和手指出现了刺痛和麻木。到了他拿不动枪的程度。医生说他脊椎里的一节椎间盘移位了。
They looked at me, did x-rays, said, hey, we need to get you out of here, sent me to Landstuhl in Germany. They looked at me and said, you're on your way home, bud.
他们看着我，拍了X光片，说，嘿，我们需要把你送走，把我送到了德国的兰施图尔（Landstuhl）。他们看着我，说，伙计，你该回家了。
Is there a downside to coming home?
回家有什么负面影响吗？
The down side to me is coming home is I'm not in Iraq with my guys. That's my downside. And the downside again is that I have to hear all the bullcrap from people that don't understand what I'm going through.
回家的负面影响是我不能和我的伙计们待在伊拉克了。那是我的负面影响。另一个负面影响是我不得不听到所有那些不了解我所经历的事情的人的废话。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
There's "if you didn't get hit with a shrapnel, you shouldn't be at home," you understand?
就是“如果你没被弹片击中，你就不应该回家”，你懂吗？
People say this to you?
人们对你说这个？
Yeah. If your arm isn't broke, you didn't get shot, so why are you at home?
是的。如果你胳膊没断，没中枪，那你为什么回家？
As they show in the film, he's actually quite hurt, in physical pain. Doctors locate the problems in MRIs and in x-rays. But in Iraq, Joe had been so vocal about how he didn't want to be there. He was more vocal than anybody we see. Some guys now think that he was just trying to get home early. Here's Matt Hertlein.
正如片中显示的，他实际上伤得很重，身体疼痛。医生在核磁共振和X光片中定位了问题。但在伊拉克，乔对他不想待在那儿的态度非常直言不讳。他比我们见过的任何人都坦率。有些人现在认为他只是想早点回家。请听马特·赫特莱恩。
A lot of people believe that that he faked the injury to go home because he was having problems with his wife.
很多人相信他伪装了受伤回家，因为他和妻子出了问题。
And what do you think?
你怎么看？
I don't know. I don't know for sure.
我不知道。我没法确定。
Did you see him when you were home?
你在家见过他吗？
No.
没有。
It bothered me in the beginning that they looked at me as if I was a deserter. It's crazy. Basically, I try not to go anywhere that much, because I don't really like dealing with public. And basically, that's all they want to talk about. So I just, I try not to, but I can't keep from it, because I got two girls that plays basketball. And so I'm out there all the time.
一开始他们把我当成逃兵看，这让我很困扰。这太疯狂了。基本上，我尽量不去任何地方，因为我不太喜欢和公众打交道。而那基本上就是他们想谈论的全部内容。所以我尽量不去，但我无法避免，因为我有两个打篮球的女儿。所以我总是去那儿。
At their games.
在她们的比赛中。
Right.
没错。
Wow. So you're at their games in this small town, so all these people you'd rather not be having to deal with, you have to deal with.
哇。所以你在那个小镇去她们的比赛，所有那些你宁愿不打交道的人，你不得不面对。
Right, exactly.
没错，正是如此。
And the guys in your unit, what kind of attitude are you getting from them?
那么你单位里的伙计们，你从他们那儿得到了什么样的态度？
At first, I was given negative attitudes from them, very negative. Because they would come home on leave, and no one would call me. They wouldn't call to say, hi, or anything. To me, that bothered me. I didn't understand that. And then I had even my platoon sergeant, he came home, didn't call me.
起初，我从他们那里得到了负面的态度，非常负面。因为他们休假回家时，没给我打过电话。他们没打电话说声“嗨”或者其他什么。这对我来说很困扰。我不理解。甚至我的排中士回家时，也没给我打电话。
I called a few of them that I knew was in. They didn't return my call. It was frustrating for me. I didn't understand it. I thought that they was just faulting me for being home. And actually, I found out, some of them really was.
我给我知道在役的几个人打了电话。他们没回电。我感到很沮丧。我不理解。我以为他们只是因为我在家而指责我。而实际上，我发现，他们有些人确实是这样。
The people signed up for the regular Army, or the Air Force, or the Navy, they and their families know that it's going to take over their lives. They're going to move from base to base. They might go to war and have to deal with that. The National Guard is different. And much of this documentary series ends up being about people, complete families, who never expected to go to war, and what war does to them.
那些报名参加正规军、空军或海军的人，他们和他们的家庭知道那会占用他们的生活。他们会从一个基地调到另一个基地。他们可能会去打仗并必须面对那个。国民警卫队则不同。这部纪录片系列大部分最终是关于那些从未预料到会去打仗的普通人，整个家庭，以及战争对他们做了什么。
Matt's mother cries on the phone with him. He grows up amazingly fast. Sergeant Short ends up proud of the work he does in Iraq, keeping his men safe. And for Joe, who was re-endlisted against his will, after all, it's hurt his marriage, given him permanent injury, and he lost his church. When he was away, attendance dropped to seven people. And then, nobody was coming to services anymore.
马特的母亲在电话里和他哭泣。他成熟得惊人。肖特中士最终对他所做的工作感到自豪，确保了部下的安全。而对于乔，那位违背意愿被重新入伍的牧师，这最终伤害了他的婚姻，让他受了永久性的伤害，并且失去了他的教堂。当他不在时，出席人数降到了7人。然后，再也没人来礼拜了。
Until his unit's deployment is finished, and the rest of them come back from Iraq, his job every day is to go to the National Guard armory, where he and two other injured guys do some paperwork, when there's paperwork to do. They sit by the phone. They answer it when it rings. He reads the paper. He started reading some technical manuals to pass the time. The phone doesn't ring much.
直到他部队的部署完成，其余人从伊拉克回来，他每天的工作就是去国民警卫队的军械库，在那里，他和另外两名受伤的队员做一些文书工作——如果有文书工作的话。他们坐在电话旁。电话响时他们接听。他读报纸。他开始阅读一些技术手册来打发时间。电话不怎么响。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "TENDER COMRADE" BY BILLY BRAGG]
[音乐播放 - 比利·布拉格的《柔情的同志》]
Coming up, the Battle of Fallujah. At the end of it, Marines wondered if this was one for the history books, if this is one that they would teach someday. When you hear one lieutenant describe what his men did, you'll understand why. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来的内容，费卢杰战役。战斗结束时，海军陆战队员想知道这是否能载入史册，这是否会成为未来教导的内容。当你听到一位中尉描述他的部下做了什么，你就会明白为什么。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we try to begin to answer a very simple question. What's it really like for American soldiers in Iraq? We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Marine Life. In this act, the most basic story that we rarely hear about war, what it's really like to fight on the ground, house to house.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在节目中，我们试图开始回答一个非常简单的问题：美国士兵在伊拉克的真实体验是什么样的？我们现在进入了节目的第二部分。第二部分，海军陆战队生活。在这一部分，我们讲述战争中最基本、却极少听到的故事：在地面上挨家挨户战斗的真实感受。
Rob Miller is a first lieutenant in the Marine Corps, commanding a weapons platoon of about 40 guys in Charlie Company. He's 30 years old. He loves the Marines. He's been a marine for a decade. In early November, Rob led his men in the Battle of Fallujah. After it was over, he talked with his uncle, Jack Hitt, by satellite phone from a camp east of the city.
罗布·米勒（Rob Miller）是海军陆战队的一名中尉，指挥着查理连一个由大约40人组成的武器排。他今年30岁。他热爱海军陆战队。他当海军陆战队员已经十年了。11月初，罗布率领他的部下参加了费卢杰战役。战斗结束后，他通过卫星电话从城市东边的一个营地与他的叔叔杰克·希特进行了交谈。
A quick word of explanation about some of the terms that Rob uses. Devil dogs and devils are Marines. Psy-ops are psychological operations. IED, of course, is Improvised Explosive Device, the booby-trap bombs that have caused the most casualties in Iraq.
关于罗布使用的一些术语，简单解释一下。“恶魔犬”和“恶魔”指的就是海军陆战队员。“心理战”是心理行动。当然，IED就是简易爆炸装置，即在伊拉克造成伤亡最多的诱杀炸弹。
Good morning, Fallujah.
早上好，费卢杰。
So, Jack, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], how are you doing?
你好啊，杰克，[听不清]，你怎么样？
How are you?
你怎么样？
I'm doing pretty good. I'm trying to light a cigarette. Right when I went on emergency leave, I ended up smoking again. And then Fallujah's like, it doesn't deny of your nicotine habits. It's like a mandatory. So people who don't smoke, now smoke. People that used to dip now dip and smoke.
我还行。我正试着点一支烟。我休紧急假的时候，最终又开始抽烟了。而费卢杰这儿，它不会让你戒掉尼古丁习惯。这简直是强制性的。所以不抽烟的人现在也抽了。以前嚼烟草的人现在又是嚼又是抽。
I say, I was absolutely out of cigarettes. And we had Marines that were coming up with these little Iraqi cigarettes. Because we were paying the interpreters to get cigarettes for all the Marines.
我是说，我当时确实没烟了。我们有海军陆战队员弄到了这些伊拉克香烟。因为我们付钱给翻译，让他们为所有士兵买烟。
And lo and behold, my old buddy friggin' sent me a package. And then it was like six packs of cigarettes. And all he wrote was, I started smoking in Fallujah when I went. Here's some smokes for you. I'm like, oh my God.
然后瞧啊，我以前的老伙计竟然给我寄了一个包裹。里面有六包烟。他写的唯一一句话就是：“我在费卢杰那会儿开始抽烟的。给你寄点烟。我也一样。”我说，天哪。
So what's been happening today?
那么今天发生了什么？
Today's pretty laid-back. All my guys are out in the old firm base. And we're still hardening the firm bases. It's pretty funny. We go to these places, and we harden these firm bases. And you fill, I don't know, 10,00, 15,000 sandbags. You lay 200 rolls of Concertina wire. You put out trip flares, fill the earthen berms. With Charlie Company, specifically, we do that for 7 to 10 days, and then they say, hey, you're moving. You're like, oh, you're kidding me. Then you turn it over to somebody else. And they're like, hey, nice firm base. You're welcome, bastard.
今天挺轻松的。我的部下都在老稳固基地里。我们还在加固那些稳固基地。这挺搞笑的。我们去这些地方，加固稳固基地。你填装了一万、一万五千个沙袋。铺设了200卷蛇腹铁丝网。布置了绊发闪光弹，填平土堤。对于查理连，特别是我们，加固7到10天，然后他们说，嘿，你们要撤了。你就像，噢，你在跟我开玩笑吧。然后你把它移交给别人。他们说，嘿，不错的稳固基地。不客气，混蛋。
So you were doing this house-to-house clearing stuff. This is what we're seeing on our TVs here.
所以你们是在做那种挨家挨户清理的事情。这就是我们在电视上看到的那些。
Oh yes. This is pretty crazy. We push from the north part of the city through the breach on foot, all the way to the center of the city. And anywhere you went, you'd look out a window, and a sniper would try to shoot you.
噢，是的。这简直太疯狂了。我们从城市北部步行穿过缺口，一直推进到城市中心。无论你走到哪儿，往窗外一望，狙击手就会试图射击你。
Every time you moved, you don't just walk across. You don't walk anywhere. Everywhere you go, you're moving to get behind cover, even if it's a telephone pole. Telephone pole, if that's all you've got, that's good cover, if that's all you got.
每次你移动时，你不仅仅是走过去。你哪儿都不敢乱走。无论去哪儿，你都在移动以躲到掩体后面，哪怕只是电线杆。电线杆，如果那是你拥有的全部，那也是不错的掩体。
I saw tons of Marines hide behind gutters in the roads, shooting from underneath gutters. Four inches of cover, that's nothing. But if all you've got's four inches, four inches is beautiful. The whole first night, we went basically two blocks the whole first night.
我看到无数海军陆战队员躲在路边的排水沟后，从沟底下射击。四英寸的掩体，那根本不算什么。但如果你只有四英寸，那四英寸简直是美妙。第一天晚上，我们基本就只前进了两个街区。
Can you describe what was it like? What did you do?
你能描述一下那是种什么感觉吗？你们做了什么？
Well they had the first day of the initial bombing. And it was actually really good. We sat all day. And we watched the city just being bombarded.
嗯，他们在那天进行了最初的轰炸。那实际上效果真的很好。我们坐了一整天。我们看着整座城市被狂轰滥炸。
They were hitting targets. They were hitting key fortifications. And people were moving around. They were hitting them. JDAMs, laser-guided bombs.
他们在打击目标。他们打击关键的防御工事。人们四处走动，他们就在打击。JDAM，激光制导炸弹。
And so we sat all day. There was this symphony of destruction. And it just played out until it got dark. And then when it got dark, it's like, all right. Now that it's dark, it's time for the grunts to go in.
所以我们坐了一整天。那是毁灭的交响乐。它一直持续到天黑。当天黑下来，就像是：好了。现在天黑了，是步兵进去的时候了。
But yeah, the first night we went in, going through the breach, this was pretty weird. We had psy-ops behind us. And they're blaring music into the city. It's just huge speakers are screaming music into the city.
但确实，我们进去的第一晚，穿过缺口，感觉非常怪异。我们身后有心理战部队。他们向城市里播放音乐。那是巨大的扬声器在向城市播放音乐。
What music?
什么音乐？
I don't know what the tune was, from Full Metal Jacket. At the very end of Full Metal Jacket, they're walking through Saigon, I think it is, or, it's one of the big battles at the end of the movie. And they're on patrol. And there's this funky '70s music going. And that's what they were blaring, as I crossed the breach. And all I could think of was Full Metal Jacket.
我不知道那是什么曲子，《全金属外壳》（Full Metal Jacket）里的。在《全金属外壳》结尾时，他们走在西贡，我想是那样，或者，是片尾的一场大战。他们在巡逻。背景里有这种时髦的70年代音乐。这就是我穿过缺口时他们放的。我脑子里能想到的只有《全金属外壳》。
And I was like, you got to be kidding me. You're playing that while I'm crossing this breach? That's not what I want to hear.
我说，你在跟我开玩笑吧。我穿过这缺口时你们在放这个？那可不是我想听的。
Yeah, what music would you have chosen?
是的，你会选择什么音乐？
"Let the Bodies Hit the Floor," that's a good one, really fast-paced. But yeah, they were just playing crazy stuff. And they've got some kind of method. I don't know how it works. It was definitely annoying me. I can't imagine what it was doing to the bad guys.
“让身体倒在地板上”（Let the Bodies Hit the Floor），那个不错，节奏很快。但确实，他们只是在放些奇怪的东西。他们有某种方法。我不知道它是怎么运作的。这绝对让我感到心烦。我无法想象这对坏蛋们有什么影响。
Yeah, we were pushing into the city. Even on certain days, you push into the city. And as you progress further, the mosques would be screaming for people to rise up. And there was one, it was the middle of the night. And we were pushing through these alleys to push forward.
是的，我们在推进到城市里。甚至在某些日子，你推入城市。随着你进一步推进，清真寺会尖叫着让人们站起来。有个清真寺，是在半夜。我们穿过这些小巷向前推进。
And I just remember this mosque, the guy on the speaker was just screaming. He was just like yelling in Arabic, a-la-la-la-la. And he's like, ha-la-la-la jihad, ha-la-la-la jihad, jihad, jihad. Ha-la-la-la-la, jihad. And I was like, God, will somebody shoot those speakers. 10 minutes later, there was just this mass of gunfire, and all the speakers went silent, because they shot all the speakers.
我还记得那座清真寺，扬声器里那家伙就在尖叫。他就像在用阿拉伯语大喊，“阿-拉-拉-拉-拉”。他说，“哈-拉-拉-拉-吉哈德，哈-拉-拉-拉-吉哈德，吉哈德，吉哈德。哈-拉-拉-拉-拉，吉哈德。”我说，天哪，谁能把那些扬声器打掉。10分钟后，枪声大作，所有的扬声器都安静了，因为他们把所有扬声器都打碎了。
The fourth day into the fight, we went from the-- I was at the [? al-Hidra ?] mosque with my mortars. And we got the word we were pushing to the mayor's complex, which is right in the center of the city. And we pushed to the mayor's complex in tracks. And we were maybe less than 100 meters between where the tracks dropped us off and the building we had to go to.
战斗的第四天，我们从……我当时带着迫击炮在[阿尔-希德拉]清真寺。我们接到消息，我们要推进到市长综合大楼，就在城市中心。我们乘车推进到大楼。我们距离车队把我们丢下的地方到我们要去的大楼之间，可能不到100米。
And our foot movement from there, it was basically a sprint, our sprint from the track all the way to the building. And we had snipers trying to peg us the whole way. Just rounds zinging by, hitting the dirt.
而我们从那里步行，基本是一次冲刺，从车上一直冲到楼里。一直有狙击手试图钉住我们。子弹嗖嗖从身边掠过，打在泥土里。
And we got into this building, and that's when we found out that the entire mayor's complex was surrounded by snipers. And they were just pinging at anybody that could frickin' walk in the open. So we initially took all our extra mortar ammunition, and each mortar can probably weighs, I don't know, 30 to 40 pounds. We have our Marines divvy up. And they're carrying mortar rounds in their pack.
我们冲进这栋楼，那时我们发现整个市长综合大楼都被狙击手包围了。他们在开阔地带，对着任何能走动的混蛋砰砰射击。所以我们最初拿出了我们所有的额外迫击炮弹，每箱弹药可能重，我不知道，30到40磅。我们让部下分配。他们把炮弹背在背包里。
And then we have an extra, probably, 8, 10 cans that we're taking into combat. So we tie these things onto these huge D9 tractors. And we cinch them down. And everything was good until we go through the breach and one of the D9s gets stuck in this huge mud bog. It sinks, because it's so heavy.
然后我们有多带了大概8到10箱进入战场。所以我们将这些东西绑在这些巨大的D9推土机上。我们把它们勒紧。一切都很好，直到我们穿过缺口，其中一辆D9陷进了一个巨大的泥坑里。它下沉了，因为它太重了。
And so we got to send people back into the breach to get our ammo. But the problem was, when they pulled it off the first D9, they cut the straps, instead of untying it. However they got it off, they cut it off and they brought it. We can't reattach it. So we had to use a casualty stretcher.
所以我们得派人回缺口取弹药。但问题是，当他们从第一辆D9上取下时，他们割断了带子，而不是解开。不管他们怎么弄下来的，他们割断了带子，把它拿走了。我们没法重新绑上去。所以我们不得不使用伤员担架。
So we use this casualty stretcher, and we heap all of our ammo on it. So when we move, I got two Marines lugging 200 pounds of ammo. You're not moving fast. You move across a road in a dead sprint carrying 200 pounds of ammo, the two of you, it's a shuffle. It's a shuffle. You're shuffling across the road, like, don't get shot. Don't get shot. Don't get shot.
所以我们用这副伤员担架，把所有的弹药堆在上面。当我们移动时，我有两个海军陆战队员拖着200磅的弹药。你不可能走得快。你带着200磅的弹药死命冲刺横穿马路，两个人拖着，那简直是磨蹭。你在马路上磨蹭着走，就像是：别中弹。别中弹。别中弹。
Oh, man. By the way, were you ever scared?
天哪。顺便问一下，你害怕过吗？
Well, to a certain degree, yeah. You're definitely freaked out at certain times. The first night we were moving forward, and it's probably the only time I was ever scared for my company and my battalion, we were pushing forward. It's pitch black. There's no moon. And it's raining, and it's drizzling.
嗯，在某种程度上，是的。在某些时刻你绝对会吓坏。我们第一晚向前移动时，可能是我唯一一次为我的连队和营感到害怕。我们在向前推进。漆黑一片。没有月亮。下着雨，飘着细雨。
And it's 40 degrees out. And everybody's freezing. And my unit's pushing forward. And it's just contact the whole way.
天气只有40度。每个人都冻僵了。我的部队向前推进。整个路上都是交火。
And all of a sudden, we get the call over the radio, we got a Marine down. We got a Marine down. We got IEDs in this alley. An IED just went off. So two Marines, they went in to get this guy. Boom. Friggin', these two other guys go down. So now they got three guys in this alley that they think is-- the whole alley is IEDs. And that was the big fear, is that there were just going to be IEDs all across the city. I was like, oh my God. We're going to take so many casualties. It's going to take forever for us to move. Can we do it? Sure. But it's going to be absolutely horrible.
突然，我们从电台接到呼叫，我们有一名队员倒下了。有一名队员倒下。这条小巷里有IED。刚刚炸了一个IED。所以两名队员进去救那个人。轰。这些该死的，又有两名队员倒下了。所以现在他们小巷里有三个人，他们认为这是……整条小巷都是IED。那是我最大的恐惧，那就是城市里全是IED。我当时想，噢，天哪。我们会伤亡这么多。我们要移动得花好久。我们做得到吗？当然。但那绝对会变得很恐怖。
At the same time, 3rd platoon had massive contact further down to the east. 1st platoon was actually held up, because they were in a massive engagement to our flank, far east. Bravo Company was just shooting all across their line. And I was like, how can they-- they wanted us to push all the way to the Hidra mosque that night. And I was like, how can they expect us to push to the Hidra mosque.
与此同时，第3排在东边更远的地方遭遇了大规模接触。第1排实际上被阻住了，因为他们在我们侧翼的远东地区参与了大规模战斗。布拉沃连（Bravo Company）在他们的整条线上射击。我当时想，他们怎么能……他们那天晚上要我们一直推到希德拉清真寺。我说，他们怎么能指望我们推到希德拉清真寺。
It's totally non-feasible. We got three Marines that are down, and they are wounded. And it was two, three minutes later that the platoon commander came back on. He's like, it wasn't IEDs. It wasn't IEDs. There's a guy in a second story, and he's frickin' throwing hand grenades in this alley.
这根本不可行。我们有三名队员倒下了，他们受伤了。两三分钟后，排长又回电了。他说，不是IED。那不是IED。有个家伙在二楼，在那小巷里往外扔手榴弹。
And so they just light this guy up with everything they own. They're throwing the kitchen sink up at this guy. They finally kill this guy.
于是他们用所有能用的火力把那家伙打成了筛子。他们把所有东西都往那人身上扔。他们最终干掉了那个家伙。
And then the same time, our tanks that were attached to us, Panzer, these guys call us. And he's actually on the road facing east. And he's like, when he calls, you can hear his 240 Golf shooting, and his 50-cal shooting. And he's just like, oh my God. He's like, you need to get somebody else down here. He's like, there's 50 to 60 people retreating from the north to south. And they're just flowing across the road. He's like I can't kill them all.
同时，附属于我们的坦克，潘泽（Panzer），打来电话。他正面对东边停在路上。他呼叫时，你能听到他的240高尔夫球和50口径机枪在射击。他当时说，噢，天哪。他说，你们得调派其他人来这儿。他说，有50到60个人正从北向南撤退。他们正流经这条路。他说我杀不完他们所有人。
And he must have killed 30, 35 people. And he didn't, he couldn't even-- I don't even know if he made a dent. They were just flowing to the south away from us.
他一定杀了30、35个人。甚至我都不确定他是否造成了影响。他们只是流向南边远离我们。
This is your second time in Iraq, correct?
这是你第二次来伊拉克，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, and the first time, you didn't see combat, anything like this, right?
是的，第一次你没见过战斗，没见过像这样的场面，对吧？
No, no, no. It was pretty cool. My platoon was the first Marine unit on the deck in Mosul. And so we got there expecting to get off and get into a firefight. But it wasn't like that. It wasn't anything like Fallujah.
不，不，不。那挺酷的。我的排是第一支登上摩苏尔的美军陆战队。所以我们到那儿时期待着下车投入火拼。但不是那样。那根本不像费卢杰。
It wasn't really out of control. As soon as we got there, CNN showed up. And they were like, the Marines are on the deck in Mosul. And then everything quieted down.
那甚至没有失控。我们一到那儿，CNN就出现了。他们说，海军陆战队已经在摩苏尔了。然后一切都平静下来了。
Everybody was like, oh, US forces are here, good to go. Everything's good. Go home, relax. And I did a lot of missions where I would go and just stand on the road and wave at cars. And I really felt like I was trying to collect money. Money for the poor. And I'm out there with a gun.
每个人都像是，噢，美军在这儿，一切都好。回家吧，休息吧。我执行了很多任务，只是站在路上向车流挥手。我真的觉得我是在筹款。为穷人募款。而我扛着枪站在那儿。
Now that you've seen combat, would you want to go into it again? Or do you feel like you're cured?
既然你见过战斗了，你想再经历一次吗？还是你觉得你已经受够了？
Yeah. It's a good question. Some people definitely are, they're like, that's it, we're done. But I don't know. It's a tough thing. It's really tough.
是的。这是个好问题。有些人绝对是，他们会说，就是这样，我们完了。但我不知道。这是一件很艰难的事情。真的很艰难。
Well, now that you--
嗯，既然你——
I will say that now that I've been in pretty intense combat, you could say, I'm like, that's good to go. We need to [UNINTELLIGIBLE] dragons, as we say. We're good. We need to get our job done and get home.
我想说，既然我已经经历了相当激烈的战斗，你可以说，我已经可以了。我们得完成任务，就像我们常说的。我们够了。我们要完成工作然后回家。
Yeah. Right. Did you ever get the boxes we sent you, of food?
是的。没错。你收到我们寄给你的食物箱了吗？
Oh, I got them. Yeah, the artichoke hearts? Yeah, that was great.
噢，我收到了。是的，那些朝鲜蓟心？是的，那太棒了。
It was mostly junk food.
那大多是垃圾食品。
Oh my God. And those artichoke hearts, I was laughing. I was laughing to tears. And a foreign observer came in, this lieutenant, and he's like, no way. I love artichoke hearts. And I was like, well you are in luck, Neville. And I was like, because I've got a whole jar of artichoke hearts that's got your name on it. And he was like, oh yeah.
天哪。那些朝鲜蓟心，我笑得流出了眼泪。一位外国观察员，这位中尉进来，他说，绝无可能。我爱吃朝鲜蓟心。我说，那你运气不错，内维尔（Neville）。我说，因为我有一整罐朝鲜蓟心是写着你名字的。他就像，噢，天哪。
But we get a lot of good stuff. We get tons of stuff from kids in schools. And we get a lot of crayon drawings that are, you know. The marine is this huge person. And the Iraqis these little small people. And we're throwing hand grenades. And they're like, run away.
但我们确实收到了很多好东西。我们收到了很多学校孩子寄来的东西。我们收到了很多蜡笔画。海军陆战队员是一个巨大的人。伊拉克人是那些小人。我们在投掷手榴弹。他们像是，快跑。
We get some, though. Especially when you get into middle school and high school, then you get the political kids. The funniest one that comes to my mind was from some youth group out of New York or something. They sent us a bunch of stuff. A couple of them were like, I think President Bush is crazy, and you got to be kidding me, and what are we doing over there.
不过我们确实收到了一些。特别是当你遇到初中生和高中生时，你会得到那些有政治倾向的孩子寄来的东西。我能想到最有趣的一个是来自纽约或其他什么地方的一个青年团体。他们寄给我们一堆东西。其中几个说，我觉得布什总统是个疯子，你在开玩笑吧，你们在那儿做什么。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
So listen, I have a joke for you. I love Black Hawks. But you know who hates them? Iraqi sheep farmers.
所以听着，我有个笑话讲给你听。我爱“黑鹰”。但你知道谁讨厌它们吗？伊拉克牧羊人。
Iraqi sheep farmers?
伊拉克牧羊人？
Yeah.
是的。
Iraqi sheep farmers hate Black Hawks. I don't get it.
伊拉克牧羊人讨厌“黑鹰”。我不明白。
OK so also on this program is this comic who's been touring in Fallujah. His name is Tom Irwin.
好了，顺便说一下，这个节目里还有一位正在费卢杰巡回表演的喜剧演员。他的名字叫托马斯·欧文。
Oh yeah, no, he was out here, and all the pogues got to watch him, because everybody else was in the field. That was pretty funny.
噢，是的，不，他在那儿，所有驻外人员都有机会看他表演，因为其他人都去前线了。那挺搞笑的。
Oh, you didn't see him.
噢，你没看。
No. We were in Fallujah. I don't know. It burns up all my boys. And they always get ticked off at that kind of stuff. They're like, why are they doing a show for them? They're not getting shot at.
没有。我们在费卢杰。我不知道。这惹恼了我的部下们。他们总是因为那种事情而生气。他们说，为什么要为他们表演？他们又没在挨枪子。
Wow, well, we can't wait to see you here back home.
哇，好吧，我们迫不及待地想在回国时见到你。
I can't wait to get back, see my little boy.
我迫不及待地想回去，看看我的小儿子。
Yeah. All right, man. Well, listen, thanks again for all this--
是的。好了，伙计。嗯，听着，再次感谢所有这些——
--talking to you.
——跟你谈话。
--al this time, yeah. Be safe, as we say. That's all we can say from back here. But anyway, we can't wait to see you.
——这段时间，是的。保重，正如我们所说的。从这儿我们只能这么说。但无论如何，我们迫不及待地想见到你。
Sounds good.
听起来不错。
All right, man.
好了，伙计。
I'm going to talk to you later. Give everybody my love, OK?
我稍后再跟你聊。替我向大家问好，好吗？
I will. All right, Rob.
我会的。好了，罗布。
All right.
好了。
Until then, bye-bye.
在那之前，再见。
Marine Lieutenant Rob Miller outside Fallujah, Charlie Company, 1st Battalion, 8th Marines, talking with his uncle, Jack Hitt, one of our regular contributors here at This American Life.
海军陆战队中尉罗布·米勒，在费卢杰外，查理连，第1营第8海军陆战团，与他的叔叔杰克·希特交谈，杰克是我们在《美国生活》的常驻撰稿人之一。
Our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Amy O'Leary, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. For more information about that TV documentary about the National Guardsmen, it's called Off to War. Type that into any search engine and you'll find their website, or go to dctvny.org.
今天的节目由温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）和我本人与亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、艾米·奥利里（Amy O'Leary）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）共同制作。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。想了解更多关于那部关于国民警卫队员的电视纪录片的信息，它叫《奔赴战场》。在任何搜索引擎中输入这个名称，你就能找到他们的网站，或者访问dctvny.org。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
Today's program and its archives are available for download at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where you can download other public radio programs and best-selling audiobooks, such as Jon Stewart's America and David Sedaris's Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim. That's audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
今天的节目及其档案可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载，你可以在那里下载其他公共广播节目和畅销有声读物，比如乔恩·斯图尔特（Jon Stewart）的《美国》（America）和戴维·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）的《Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim》。那是audible.com/thisamericanlife。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight from Mr. Torey Malatia, who has this message for his followers.
WBEZ管理监督来自托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他向他的追随者传达了这条信息。
Ha-la-la-la-la, jihad. Ha-la-la, jihad. Jihad, jihad. Ha-la-la, jihad.
哈-拉-拉-拉-拉，吉哈德。哈-拉-拉，吉哈德。吉哈德，吉哈德。哈-拉-拉，吉哈德。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。